in the last video I Don the idea of a
sigma bond and that was a bond where let
me draw two nucleuses and let me just
draw one of the orbitals let's say this
is an sp3 hybridized orbital and that's
on this atom and this is kind of its big
lobe right there and then this guy has
an sp3 hybridized orbital as well that's
the small lobe and then that's the big
lobe like that a sigma bond is one where
there's an overlap kind of in the
direction in which the lobes are pointed
and you might say well you know how can
there be any other type of bond than
that well the other type of bond so this
right here let me make this clear this
right here this right here is a sigma
sigma bond you say well you know what
what other kind of bond could there be
where my two over my two orbitals
overlap kind of in the direction that
they're pointing and the other type of
bond you could have you can imagine if
you have two P orbitals so let me draw
to the nucleus of two atoms and I'll
just draw one of each of their P
orbitals so let's say that that's the
nucleus and I'll just draw their p
orbital so p orbital is just that
dumbbell shape let me draw it a little
bit
let me draw them a little bit closer
together so p orbital is that dumbbell
shape so let me draw this guy's one of
his P orbitals a little bit bigger than
that and you'll see why in a second so
one of his P orbitals right there it
comes out like that and then this guy
over here also has a p orbital that is
parallel to this p orbital so it goes
like that so it goes like that well let
me draw that other one a little bit
straighter it goes I want it to overlap
more so it goes like that I think you
get the idea so here our 2p orbitals are
parallel to each other this do you could
imagine these are sp3 hybridized
orbitals they're pointing at each other
here they're parallel p-orbitals
parallel to each other and you see that
they overlap on this kind of top lobe
here and in this bottom lobe here and
this is a PI a PI bond
so let me make this clear that is a and
this is one PI bond so you could call it
two pi literally with the Greek letter
pi PI bond sometimes you'll see this as
just written as PI bond and it's written
it's called a PI bond because it's the
Greek letter for essentially P and we're
dealing with P orbitals overlapping now
Sigma bonds which nor are what form when
you have a single bond these are
stronger than PI bonds pi bonds come
into play once you start forming double
or triple bonds on top of a sigma bond
to kind of get a better visualization of
how that might work let's think about
ethene ethene so it's chemical its
molecular structure looks like this let
me so you have C double bonded to C and
then you have each of those guys have
two hydrogen's each of those guys have
two hydrogen's so let me draw what it
would look like or our best visual or
our best ability to kind of
conceptualize what these what the
orbitals around the carbon might look
like so let me draw let me draw so first
I'll draw I'll draw the sp2 hybridized
orbitals so let me just make it very
clear what's going on here so when we
when we were dealing with methane when
we were dealing with methane so methane
which is literally just a carbon bonded
to four hydrogen's and if I actually
wanted to draw it in a way that it kind
of looks a little three-dimensional with
a tetrahedral structure it might look
like this this hydrogen is pointing out
a little bit this hydrogen is kind of in
the plane of the page and then maybe
that hydrogen is behind it and then you
have one hydrogen popping up that's
methane and we saw that these were all
sp3 hybridized orbitals around the
carbon and then they each formed Sigma
bonds with each of the hydrogen's we saw
that in the last video and when we drew
its electron configuration in order for
this to happen
carbons electron configuration in when
bonding in methane needed to look like
this it needed to look like one s2 and
then having and then you have and then
instead of having two s2 and
in 2p to what you essentially have is
let me write it this way actually if
it's better let me write it this better
in 1s you had two electrons and then in
instead of 2's you had two electrons in
each of the peas you had one the s is
and the peas all got mixed up the s is
and the peas all got mixed up and you
had a - sp3 hybridized orbital another -
sp3 hybridized orbital another - sp3
hybridized orbital and then another one
sp3 normally when carbon sitting by
itself you would expect an S 2's here
and then you'd have a 2p in the
x-direction a 2p in the y-direction and
then a 2p in the z direction but we saw
in the last video they all get mixed up
and they all have a 25% s character and
a 75% p character when carbon bonds and
methane and then the electrons kind of
separate out in that situation when
you're dealing with the carbons in
ethene when you're dealing with the
carbons in ethane remember earth is for
two carbons and ian's because we're
dealing with an alkene we have a double
bond here in this situation the carbons
electron configuration when they bond in
ethene looks more like this so you have
your 1s and then you have your and the
1s orbital is still completely full it
has two electrons in it but then in your
in your two shell you have so let me
just I'll just write let me do this in a
different color so in our two shell I'll
show you what I mean in the second I'm
not writing the s or PS so far on
purpose but we're gonna have we're going
to have four electrons just like we had
before we're still forming four bonds
we're gonna have kind of these four
unpaired electrons we're still forming
one two three four bonds with each of
the carbon so they're going to be
separated out they are going to be
separated out but in this situation
instead of all of them being a mixture
kind of one part s three parts p the S
mixes with two of the P orbitals so what
you have is 2 SP 2 2 SP 2 2 SP 2
orbitals so you can imagine that the S
orbital mixes with two of the p orbital
so now it's one part s2
parts p and then one of the P orbitals
kind of stays by itself and we need this
p orbital to stay by itself because it
is going to form it is going to be
what's responsible for the pi bond and
we're going to see that the pi bond does
something very interesting to the
molecule it kind of makes it up
unrotated around a bond axis and you'll
see what I mean in a second so let me
see if I can in three dimensions draw
each of these carbons each of these
carbons so you have so you have let me
do it a different color you have this
carbon right there so let's say that's
the nucleus although I'll put a C there
so you know which carbon we're dealing
with and then I'll draw we you know you
could assume that the 1s the 1s orbital
it's really small right around the
carbon and then you have these
hybridized orbitals the two sp2 orbitals
and they're all going to be planar kind
of forming a triangle or I guess maybe a
ap sign on some level but I'll try to
draw it in three dimensions here so you
have one this is kind of coming out a
little bit then you have one that's
going in a little bit and then you have
and they have another you know lobe a
little bit on the other side but I'm not
going to draw a little complicated
they're still have characteristics of P
so they'll have two lobes but one is
bigger than the other and then you have
one that's maybe going in this side so
you can imagine that this is kind of a a
Mercedes sign on if you draw a circle
around it on its side so that's this
carbon right here and of course it has
its hydrogen's so you have you have this
hydrogen there and so this hydrogen
might be sitting right here it just has
one electron and it's 1s and it's 1s
orbital you have this hydrogen up here
it's sitting right over there and now
let's draw this carbon now let's draw
this carbon this carbon will be sitting
I'm drawing pretty close together this
carbon will be sitting right there
he has his 1s orbital there they have
the exact same electron configuration he
has his 1s orbital right around him and
then he has the exact same configuration
and either of these guys we've so far
only or in this first guy I've only
drawn these first three I haven't drawn
this this unhybridized p orbital
so I'll do that in a second but let me
draw his bonds so first of all he has
this or you could imagine that bond
right there
which would be an sp2 hybridized bond
let me do that in the same color as so
he has this bond right here which would
be an sp2 hybridized bond just like that
and notice this is a sigma bond they
overlap in kind of the direction that
they're pointing in that's the best way
I could think about it and then he's got
these two hydrogen's so one he's got
this guy in the back this guy in the
back and then there's one in the front
I'll draw it a little bigger so it's
kind of pointing out at us all right and
then we have this hydrogen is sitting
right over here and these are also Sigma
bonds just to be very clear about things
this is a s orbital overlapping with an
sp2 orbital but they're kind of
overlapping in the direction that
they're pointed or kind of along the
direction of each other of the two atoms
this is a sigma bond sigma bond and then
we have this hydrogen in the back we
have this hydrogen in the back which is
also going to form a sigma bond so
everything I've drawn so far is a sigma
bond so that that maybe I don't want to
maybe I don't want to make this picture
too so I could just put Sigma bond there
Sigma bond there Sigma bond there Sigma
Sigma so so far I've drawn I have drawn
this bond this bond this bond this bond
and this bond all of those Sigma bonds
so what happens to this last p orbital
for each of these guys well that's going
to be kind of sticking out of the plane
of the Mercedes sign it's the best way I
can I can describe it and let me see if
I can do that in a color that I haven't
done yet only this purple color so you
could imagine a pure p orbital so a pure
p orbital and draw it I need to draw it
even bigger than that actually a pure p
orbital it normally wouldn't be that big
relative to things but I have to make
them overlap so it's a pure p orbital a
pure p orbital that's kind of going in
maybe you can imagine the z-axis that
the other orbitals are
Marcedes sign and the xy-plane and now
you have the z axis going straight up
and down and those bottom two have two
overlaps let me draw them bigger so it
looks like that and it looks like that
and they're going straight up and down
and notice they are now overlapping so
these this bond right here is this bond
if you know I could have drawn them in
either way but it's that second bond and
so what's happening now to the structure
so let me make it very clear this right
here that is a PI bond and this right
here is also it's the same PI bond it's
this guy right here it's the second bond
in the double bond but what's happening
here well first of all by itself it
would be a weaker bond but because we
already have a sigma bond since we
already have a sigma bond that's kind of
a track that's forming making these
molecules come closer together this PI
bond will make them come even closer
together so this distance right here is
closer than if we were to just have a
single Sigma bond there now on top of
that the really interesting thing is if
we just had a sigma bond here both of
these molecules could kind of rotate
around the bond axis they would be able
to rotate around they would be able to
rotate around the bond axis if you just
had one Sigma bond there but since we
have these PI bonds that are parallel to
each other and they're kind of
overlapping and they're kind of locked
into that configuration you can no
longer rotate if one of these molecules
rotates the other one's going to rotate
with it because these two guys are
locked together so what this PI bond
does in this situation is it makes this
carbon-carbon double bond or it means
that the double bonds are going to be
rigid that you can't have one molecule
you can't have one molecule kind of
flipping swapping these two hydrogen's
without the other one having to flip
with it so you wouldn't be able to kind
of swap configurations of the hydrogen's
relative to the other side that's what
it causes so hopefully that gives you a
good understanding of the difference
between Sigma and PI bond and in your if
you're curious when you're dealing with
when you're dealing with just to kind of
make it clear if we were dealing with
f-fine so that we just this is the
example of ethene but ethene looks like
this you have a triple bond and so you
have each side bonding to one hydrogen
in
in this case you one of these so the
first bonds you can imagine so these
bonds are all Sigma bonds that actually
SP hybridized you that your to s orbital
only mixes with one of the peas so these
are these are SP SP hybrid orbitals
orbitals forming Sigma bonds so all of
these right here and then both of these
both of let me do this in a different
color
both of these are PI bonds and if you
have to imagine it if you have to
imagine it you could imagine another PI
bond kind of coming out of the page and
another one here coming out of the page
and into the page out and into the page
and they too are overlap and you just
have one hydrogen pointing out in each
direction maybe I'll make another video
on that so hopefully I didn't confuse
you too much